あ
汚いなぁ北代たがまあ仕方ないか
a ただいま朝の9時ちょっと過ぎたくらいなんですけども
今日を持つランして私はず3冊をする僕の周りの人達全員で
東京に引っ越します
[音楽]
秋には帰ってくるんだけどねちょっとこのなぜが非常に忙しすぎてちょっともう本当に
静岡東京の駅してる暇もないくらいになってきたんでパッチ9月ぐらいの間はほぼ全部
東京にいることになります本当にちょっとね静岡でゆっくりできる時間もなく質問
コーナーはね7月の下旬にはやる予定ですって言ってたんですけども結局
ちょっとバタバタ者でできなくて本当に申し訳ないです
[音楽]
言ってってくれておいてよかった質問コーナーに感謝東京に着いてからちょっと時間
見つけてやるのでもうしばしお待ちください本当ねー
できれば静岡にずっと言いたかったところではあるんですけどもやむを得ず東京に行っ
ちゃうみたいな感じになるんですけど
ナース不安ですねこの辺で目指す今まで動画を撮ってきたしここの居心地が良すぎて
拠点を変えたくなかったというと待って
正直ちょっと静岡部がこの部屋で動画とってたいんですけどとりあえず向こうで生活
できるようにしなきゃいけないのでちょっとある程度パソコンとか機材を全部まとめて
今日1
を引っ越すということでお引越し肇社長の一日をちょっと動画にしてみようと思います
それでも次メンバーが来るのでそれまで僕はちょっと編集しなきゃいけなって先週行っ
てきますでは
[音楽]
[拍手]
うちの母から届いたやつなんですけど右音を書きまくるという
いたずらですねね
だけどございます a
汚い豊胸を言ったら代々木公園とかでさあフリスビーしたいねー
あーたの須藤ね上手っ子
[音楽]
[拍手]
ana
[音楽]
themes
あとこれうまかざねバカ最中だよねー
ちょっと待ってなくなかった
[音楽]
can give me
もういいいい
せーの比喩はです
can you do
はいみなさんおつかれさまでしたーー
なかったねーなかった東京に着いたんですけども
パソコンとか撮影機材とかを色々この部屋に今では入れていきます
いい
テンション低いがこの様子をずっとやりますと
ん
[音楽]
me
入って言え無事静雄皿東京への引っ越しが終わりました合うけど
だわかった1パソコンの木際もカメラも服とかも全部
もう完全に東京に移行して将大第二一番から
で増加にいるんですけどもたまに来てくれる感じで匠が3000にも東京で一緒に生活
してくれますそういうわけでこれから東京ではサプレが
増えると思うんですけども
[音楽]
力を合わせて
頑張っていければいいなと思っております
頑張ってるぞ思ふ
[音楽]
me
uh